good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight last night on this show
we played you a clip from a nearly
hour-long video produced by two
physicians in California
doctors Dan Erickson and Artemis ehi
likely many of you had already seen it
that video has had more than 5 million
views on YouTube in their presentation
the two doctors presented a flurry of
data pointing to what we are currently
learning about this virus and how it
spreads they recited pages of government
statistics and then interpreted them in
light of their own long clinical
experience as doctors at one point they
noted that the newly adjusted death rate
in their state of California which is
much lower than anyone expected it to be
and they asked if government officials
there should change their policies based
on this new science watch we've seen one
thousand two hundred and twenty seven
deaths in the state of California with a
possible incidence or prevalence of four
point seven million that means you have
a 0.03 chance of dying from kovat 19 the
state of California 0.03 chance of dying
from kovat in the state of California is
that does that necessitate sheltering in
place does that necessitate shutting
down medical systems does that
necessitate people being out of work so
whatever your view of the mass
quarantines and maybe your
enthusiastically for them the questions
you just heard are valid questions in
fact they're critical questions we
should all be asking those questions
including and especially our policy
makers but as dr. Erickson pointed out
later in the video dissent of any kind
is no longer tolerated in this country
fact-based
honesty which is the soul of science is
under attack even in hospitals dr.
Erickson described physicians being
pressured to classify illnesses and
deaths as related to coronavirus whether
they believe that to be true or not we
aren't pressured to test for flu but ER
doctors now my friends if I talk to say
you know it's interesting when I'm when
I'm writing up my death report I'm being
pressured to add kovat why is that why
are we being pressured to add
to maybe increase the numbers and make
it look a little bit worse than it is I
think so
so what sheet is heard with dr. Erickson
described is called lying and lying has
no place in science ever it's scary to
think it takes place on a large scale in
hospitals he says it does viewers of
Erikson's video were shocked and
transfixed by this they forwarded the
video to friends who forward on to their
friends and suddenly millions of people
who have spent the last 6 weeks on a
diet of tiger king and internet memes
were watching sober-minded medical
researchers reading from charts of
statistics it's hard to recall a science
video taking off like this one did not
everyone was impressed by it some
criticized the doctors policy
conclusions and of course that's fair
decent people have different opinions
we're not entirely certain with the
perfect response to this pandemic is
nobody is certain there's no objective
answer at the moment at best we can plot
along with open minds and good faith
more informed debate is exactly what we
need to make wise decisions going
forward unfortunately for all of us
informed debate is exactly what the
authorities don't want they want
unquestioned obedience so they're
cracking down on free expression last
night the doctors video the one you just
saw was pulled off of YouTube the
largest video hosting site in the world
it wasn't an accident
YouTube admitted doing it the company
cited a violation of quote Community
Guidelines and they did not apologize
looking back when all of this is finally
over and it will be it's likely we'll
see this moment what YouTube just did as
a turning point in the way we live in
this country a sharp break with 250
years of law and custom the two doctors
video was produced by a local television
channel in California it was in effect a
mainstream news story the video was not
pornographic it didn't violate copyright
or incite violence or commit libel it
didn't break any law the only
justification for taking it down was
that the two physicians on screen had
reached different conclusions from the
people currently in charge it was a form
of dissent form orthodoxy YouTube and
its parent company Google have now
officially banned
and the CEO of YouTube admitted that
openly but then we also talked about
removing information that is problematic
you know of course anything that is
medically unsubstantiated to people
saying like the take vitamin C you know
take tumeric like those are all will
cure you those are the examples of
things that would be a violation of our
policy anything that would go against
World Health Organization
recommendations would be a violation of
our policy and so remove is another
really important part of our policy so
you're not just putting in the truth
next to the lie you're taking the lie
down that's a pretty aggressive approach
we're removing quote anything that would
go against World Health Organization
recommendations it'll now be taken off
the internet consider that for a minute
as a matter just of science it's
ludicrous like everyone else involved in
global pandemic policy the w-h-o has
often been wrong in its recommendations
a lot of people have in mid-january
w-h-o told us that coronavirus could not
spread from person to person in March
they told us that face masks didn't work
those relies and they were welcome on
Google's platforms doctors who were
actually treating patients with the
virus meanwhile have just been banned so
no this is not about science censorship
never is about science it's about power
big technology companies are using this
tragedy to increase their power over the
American population they're working in
concert with politicians in order to do
it just today Facebook removed an events
page for a political protest in Michigan
Governor Gretchen Whitmer who runs that
state was no doubt pleased to see it
grossly mismanaging an entire state is a
lot easier when citizens are not allowed
to complain about it another not last
week Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg
explained that protests like these are
no longer protected political speech
their quote misinformation organized a
lot of those protests to defy such a
distance
to find the social business the
guidelines in States it's somebody
trying to organize something like that
all wrong information we do classify
that as harmfulness information and we
take that down harmful misinformation
that is a phrase familiar to anyone who
has watched totalitarian regimes in any
country it's now how mark zuckerberg
describes political opinions he doesn't
like our free press exists to push back
against obvious abuses of power like
this one it's the reason we have a first
amendment it's the only reason we have a
first amendment but suddenly our media
are not concerned about freedom of
speech
reporters applaud our overlords as they
punish us for disagreeing you just saw
it in that clip from CNN that happens
every day our media are no longer
challenging power they are colluding
with power and that may be why there's
been so little critical coverage of the
massive expansion of our surveillance
state currently in progress in the name
of fighting the coronavirus tech
companies are now following you through
your cell phone they're watching you
from above with drones those sound like
paranoid fantasies they are not it's
happening as we speak
needless to say our politicians approve
of this how do you feel about the drones
look at this point we need to save lives
and it's really important that in public
spaces people are abiding by the
directives yeah we've got to do it so
what do we have here we have big
companies partnering with the government
to spy on you without your knowledge
Americans locked in their homes banned
from going to church placated with
sedatives like weed and beer anyone who
speaks up is silenced political
demonstrations are illegal organizers
are arrested only opinions approved by
leaders many of them unelected are
allowed on information platforms does
that sound familiar it sounds a lot like
China of all the many ironies of this
moment so many of them bitter the
hardest to swallow is this one as we
fight this virus we are becoming far
more like the country that spawned it we
are becoming more like China it's
horrifying
and it tells you everything that our
professional
enthusiastically welcomes this over the
weekend the Atlantic magazine published
an article by two academics calling for
an end to freedom of speech in America
their model for an ideal system the
totalitarian government of China quote
in the debate over freedom versus
control of the Internet
China was largely correct and the u.s.
was wrong and quote you ought to read
the whole thing truly you should it's
the future we get quote from it from the
rest of the show but we'll give you just
one more quote significant monitoring
and speech control are inevitable
components of a mature and flourishing
Internet and governments must play a
large role in these practices to ensure
that the Internet is compatible with
society's norms and values end quote
norms and values whose norms and values
well our leaders norms and values of
course but mostly their interests those
in power are the ones our professional
class seeks to protect not the rest of
the country freedom of conscience never
in dangers the public it only threatens
the powerful it endangers their control
it hinders their ability to dictate
election results to loot the economy to
make policies based on whim for their
own gain no wonder our leaders have done
such a poor job protecting us from China
they're on the same team dave rubin is
the author of the fantastic new book
don't burn this book it came out today
we're happy to have him on tonight Dave
thanks so much for coming on tonight
good good to have you do you notice that
the norms and standards to quote the
Atlantic of American life seems to have
changed overnight and all of a sudden
we're being told we must accept things
that would have been completely
unimaginable two months ago well Tucker
there's so much to talk about here first
off I didn't realize I was going to be
on a sci-fi show tonight but we are and
during a distant future we are entering
an authoritarian future because as I've
said to you before authoritarians love
authoritarianism so they're taking this
opportunity when we're all confused
we're all locked at home the only way we
can communicate with each other
through their pipes is through YouTube
and Facebook and Twitter and everything
else and they're actually finally saying
to us this is who we are I mean the
Atlantic is ridiculous I don't know
anyone that reads it anymore but but the
bigger issue here is is the YouTube
Twitter Facebook component of it because
we are now saying to them or they're
saying to us we're gonna tell you what's
true and if you dare go against what we
say is true not necessarily what is true
but what we say is true then we're gonna
boot you so the the of course the other
part of this is that it will always only
be one side that gets booted here I mean
is Facebook running around and is
Twitter and YouTube running around are
they taking away all the Russian
collusion videos that were up over the
past couple years a pretty sure MSNBC
has a YouTube channel that still has
videos on it I mean that was pushing
lies and misinformation and propaganda
so we need to debate these things if I
was to interview these two doctors that
you showed the video of would my channel
be deleted am I not allowed to talk
about that is that not what science and
open inquiry really is about that you
test theories and then you find out what
actually is true and as you pointed out
and this may be the most important part
it's not as if the w-h-o is infallible
they were literally just a few weeks ago
telling us not to wear masks now by law
I tried to go to CBS yesterday and I
wasn't going to wear a mask I was just
gonna run in and out and it said in the
front of the store it said by law you
have to wear a mask so it's not as if
these people have some you know some
total stranglehold on truth that the
rest of us have to bow to unless they
force us to and unfortunately big tech
has got us now more than ever because
we're all trapped at home and it's the
only way we can communicate so no one in
science has a monopoly on the truth
science in fact as a rejection of the
idea that there is a monopoly on truth
it's the endless search for what we can
prove that's what science is they this
has nothing to do with it you introduces
a hypothetical the notion that you could
be deleted your channel for hosting this
video I'm not sure that is hypothetical
anymore and my question is very simple
how long before they come for you you
just sort of book called don't burn this
book how long before they come for the
show since your questions
yeah well I at some level I don't want
to think about it but you know Tucker
you've written a couple books and you
know that the publishing process takes
quite some time so I finished this book
back in July but I'm very proud that the
ideas that I present and don't burn this
book are more relevant now than they
even were then because I talk about big
tech I talk about fake news all of the
things that we're constantly talking
about and am I worried yeah I'm worried
I mean look anyway everyone should be
worried everyone should be worried this
is why I started locals calm my tech
company because I think we need digital
homes anyone that's online and you think
that YouTube or Facebook or Twitter is
there to protect you you're the product
I mean these things are free accept free
meaning they just took your soul in
exchange for it
we should own our data you should own
your own content we need to start
rethinking everything I mean I think
this is why I'm actually quite enthused
about the world right now is as
depressing and upsetting as some of the
news is you know there's a new world
coming on the horizon and I think a lot
of people are rethinking the way they
look at the world the way do you want to
commute do you want to live in a big
city do you want to be so reliant on the
institutions and systems that we've
always been reliant on so I think we
have to rethink things and you know what
Tucker this is still America for a
little while and I believe in
old-fashioned hard work and competition
in jindo and ingenuity and I think
that's what will fix this but yeah we're
we got a we got a big battle to fight in
front of us yeah and and maybe some cook
I mean these companies exist because
Congress gave them a carve out in
federal legislation and you sort of
wonder where is Senator Mike Lee on this
question sucking up to Google did great
to see you tonight thank you very much
this is one of the in congrats on the
right thanks Tucker